hi i'm vanessa prodomo and this is
bloomberg quick take new york city fc
has officially captured the club's first
mls championship in a cinematic win over
the portland timbers over the weekend it
took the club less than 10 years to
reach the feet of champions having
played their inaugural season in 2015 as
part of the mls expansion
this to talk about this historic moment
i'm joined in studio by team captain
sean johnson
sean thanks so much for joining us in
studio thanks for having me yeah so
let's talk about this game dramatic
you're less than one second away from
hoisting this like less than one minute
away from hoisting this
and they even out the game what's going
through your mind then to be honest it
felt like it was less than a second away
um you know the the guys fought hard
hard over the 90 minutes um and right at
the end i think it was the very last
play of the game crazy sequence all of a
sudden they score
their crowd goes wild it was kind of one
of those like you know picture perfect
moments for a movie and then all of a
sudden regular time was done so
uh just have to get the guys together
after that uh regroup and then say look
we got 30 minutes to win this thing
let's uh let's do it and then then we uh
we locked in we walked in so after those
30 minutes you don't get done yet so now
you got to go into pk's goalkeeper to
goalkeeper here
penalty kicks there's nothing like the
adrenaline that goes through your body
in that moment and
saving that first kick there's like it
just
for me it gives all the confidence is
that how you felt after saving that
first one you were like i'm ready we're
winning this one yeah so so penalty
kicks as you know as a goalkeeper like
those are the moments you want like even
though like some people think it's super
nervy as a kid you always dream about
that moment where you can step in be a
hero for your team but then you get the
moment you're like oh this is real
but yeah saving the first pk you know
there's no other feeling like it because
the other team sees that all of a sudden
it puts doubt in their heads then the
second pk after the second save you know
after that my emotions just went you
know haywire and that's when it all came
out and uh the boys did the rest they
had to score the goals so pressure was
on them for me it was more so just
trying to help them yeah you're like my
job's done they say once you once you
save one you should win the game yeah
you save two yeah so i i saved one then
their goalkeeper saved one which is very
rare the first you know first couple
saves there but saving two i think we
had a pretty good chance of winning it
all yeah for sure
so now you guys are the bringing back
the first championship to new york in a
decade really since the giants won in
2011. what does that mean to you guys
yeah it means the world to us i think
you know to be a part of history in the
city um you know for this club you know
like you said ten years in the making
for for the city it's a sports city um
you know all the all the fans that have
such high expectations um you know
there's been a drought for a while um
you know for our club i've been here for
five years and to bring you know the
first mls cup back to this city the
first in 10 years means everything
because i know how much it means to the
city and the fans and to do it in the
fashion we did it
you know it's something something that's
you know only dreamt about and now it's
reality
so how many championships do you think
you have to want to be the new captain
of new york i mean you play in yankee
stadium ah that's a good question yeah
we'll start with one we'll start with
one and go from there but you know
that's the expectation we're gonna enjoy
this enjoy the moment surrounding you
know the first but we also know that
it's the standard now you know that's
going to be the expectation that's how
new york fans are they get one they want
more uh we obviously want more as well
so we're committed to doing that but i
think right now i think you have to
enjoy these moments because you never
know how long it's going to take to
happen again for sure absolutely so
soccer is the world's favorite sport
america's had some struggle with keeping
it
as popular as other sports but the mls
has really grown a lot in the last
couple of years
you said you've been with the team for
five years you've been in the league
longer than that how have you seen the
change from the way fans come to the
games now engagement from what it was
when you first joined to now in 2021
yeah so you know i came in the league
back in
2010 was my first year so you know 12
years in the making for me it's been uh
tremendous to see the growth of soccer
in this league
when i came into the league
you know the the standard uh how things
were done the quality of players the
quality of play all those things have
increased tenfold and and to see
where we are now
as a country soccer wise as a city
soccer wise is incredible so i think
you're going to see that continue to
increase you know we have the world cup
coming
you know next year and then hosting a
world cup in 2026 so i think in the next
you know five six years you're going to
see a real boom if you haven't before
and
it's just incredible that you know our
country is going to be kind of you know
a cornerstone of what's going to be
looked at as you know i think a soccer
mecca i think we're on the way oh you
think so i think right there with
england and germany and all brazil
everyone i don't think we're far off i
don't think we're off we uh you know now
we're starting to compete teams are
starting to compete on another level we
have a concacaf champions league
that we play in it's a league of
champions with our current region and
mls teams are done a fantastic job and i
think you'll start to see
our teams be respected on a world level
so i'm excited about that all right so
we're right there and then how does the
mls get to the level of popularity in
the u.s that the nfl and the nba are at
yeah so i think you know with nfl mba
those have kind of been past times
american tradition over a very long
period of time european soccer's kind of
been that you know as well for them so
i think really just looking to this time
period that we're in right next year
again being the world cup year 2026
hosting in a country that's a really big
deal and i think you'll see the
excitement with the lead up to that and
i think the world will stop i think
every other sport will stop to watch a
world cup it's the biggest sporting
spectacle
in the world and
i'm really really excited to see what
that's going to bring for this country
because
i remember back in i think it was 2014
watching the world cup from i was in
chicago at the time
the whole city stopped and paused and
i'm sure new york and new york did as
well so it's going to be it's going to
be something it's going to be something
special yeah for sure i mean 2026
i can't wait till we get there but it
seems a little far off now let's talk
about 2022 the world cup you brought it
up you also represent the us on the
men's national team
is that where you're looking towards
next now you got your mls cup title
is your next goal the world cup yeah
that's that's the goal for sure you know
i think it being a reality now being a
part of world cup qualifiers
putting ourselves in a position uh to
qualify we're in a great position now
three qualifiers coming up at the end of
january in that window which is super
important for us but yeah 2022 is
definitely the goal for me it's been a
dream of mine to go to a world cup
worked extremely hard
starting to check off some goals off the
list now it's taken me a little bit but
you know it's all part of the journey
you know for cmls cub now being a
position to qualify for the world cup i
think to to have that duo in two years
um you know something i never really
thought would would happen um so close
together but but now again that's a
reality so i'm going to try to make that
happen how sure are you that you guys
are going to get to qatar
i think we're we're pretty confident
group you know we're sure i think it's
uh you know again we have high
expectations in our group we put
ourselves in a good position to qualify
and the only thing that matters to us is
is that end goal so every every game now
is a step along the way
it's uh it's just a hurdle we have to
overcome every team standing in our way
now of achieving that and we got a
hunger group of players so i'm sure no
one's going to stand in our way so we'll
we'll put our best foot forward and
definitely uh definitely look to to be
in the 2022 world cup
and what is the thing that you think
that will get you there what about you
this team makes it different than the
2018 team that missed the the world cup
yeah i think this group of players you
know i think you know this group of
players is very familiar with each other
um there's there's a brotherhood that we
talk about
that's that's the word we refer to um
and when we look back at it i think it's
it's the the body of work that everybody
has done it's not just the guys
in one game but it's the collective it's
the staff it's the you know the kind of
family mentality that we have i think
being willing to fight for each other
and leave it all out there no matter
what the situation circumstance i think
we've we've been battle tested in a lot
of situations and uh in every situation
we've been there for each other so i
think that's gonna going to carry us a
long way for sure all right well we'll
look to see that in 2022. sean thanks so
much for joining us